minsk elfter april 2012 in der zentrale
des russischen geheimdienstes kgb
dessen chef war dem sef und zwei seiner
offiziere planen regimekritiker im
ausland zu ermorden
sie ahnen nicht dass ihr gespräch
mitgeschnitten wird im visier des
geheimdienstes ein regimekritischer
journalist pawel sheremet wir sollten
uns mit sheremet beschäftigen dieser
nervensäge
wir zünden eine bombe und diese
verfluchte rate wird in stücke gerissen
die arme in die eine richtung die beine
in die andere eine bombe zu zünden ist
überhaupt kein problem
kiew zwanzigster juli 2016 739 vier
jahre nach dem mord auftrag explodiert
in der hauptstadt der ukraine eine
autobombe
sie tötet den journalisten pavel
sheremet er wird 45 jahre alt berlin im
januar 2021
auch dieser mann soll ermordet werden
oleg alkan der ehemalige bälle russische
offizier und gefängnisdirektor lebt seit
20 jahren im deutschen exil
als ich im fernsehen sah wie das auto in
die luft flog und wie sie nach seinen
leichenteilen suchten wurde mir klar
die sache ist sehr ernst und ich empfand
unermesslicher trauer und zorn
denn ich war mit schirm at befreundet er
hat meine bücher verlegt
zb das buch das erschießungskommandos
mit harten vorwürfen gegen die
sicherheitsbehörden von belarus
deshalb sind wir ihr ziel aber ich habe
keine angst du wirst ja verrückt wenn du
über altlasten täter vermutet das
abgehörte gespräch von 2012 belegt der
in deutschland lebende dissident akajew
galt dem geheimdienst als leichte beute
um all greif musst du dich nicht kümmern
das ist eher was für einen lehrling das
soll jemand anders machen
eine idee geheimdienstoffiziere
einschleusen in die dissidentenszene im
exil
ich fahre hin als opfer des regimes
das ist ziemlich leicht ich besorge mir
eine einladung bekommen ein visum und
fuhr los
präsident alexander lukaschenko herrscht
wie ein diktator
demonstranten werden niedergeknüppelt
eingesperrt gefoltert
lukaschenko lässt auf demonstranten
schießen wie dieses video vom 10
august 2020 belegt und wer ins ausland
fließt ist vor dem regime nicht sicher
auch das wird aus dem geheimdienst
mitschnitt klar
[Musik]
der präsident erwartet klare maßnahmen
die der kgb ausführen soll
die methoden sind klar wer soll wo
ertränkt oder erschossen werden wie kann
man eine explosion oder ein feuer als
unfall tarnen um jemanden umzubringen
dafür gibt es mehr als anderthalb
millionen dollar auf einem speziellen
konto gerade ein system im todeskampf
und diktatoren im endkampf wenn man das
so will sind hoch brisant hochgefährlich
und lukaschenko zeigte er auch dass er
mit den letzten vertrauten einen krieg
gegen die eigene bevölkerung führt und
die gefahr eben auch ist dass er im
ausland versucht mit langem arm gezielt
zu töten es ist eine gefahr für diese
menschen die müssen wir ernst nehmen
alex acker wird von deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden beschützt
dafür hat dieser mann gesorgt igor
makaber offizier einer belle russischen
anti terror einheit 2006 hat er die
seiten gewechselt
seitdem lebt er im exil in litauen 2012
wurde ihm der audiomitschnitt zugespielt
der die mordpläne des weißrussischen kgb
belegt
ich hörte dass sie über meinen freund
oleg alkali versprachen dass sie seine
ermordung planten und jemand deshalb
nach deutschland fahren sollte ich
wusste ich muss irgendetwas tun um das
leben von als ich wandte mich an einen
us diplomaten mit der bitte dieses
verbrechen zu verhindern
nach einer weile erfuhr ich dass die
deutsche polizei illegal kf gewarnt hat
dass er in lebensgefahr schwebt und dass
sie ihn beschützt neben alain kalkar
will der russische geheimdienst noch
mindestens zwei weitere dissidenten in
deutschland umbringen belegt das
abgehörte gespräch
wo ist die garantie dass das thema
auftragsmord acta gelegt wurde
im gegenteil die lage in belarus hat
sich total verschärft deshalb halte ich
mich an einige sicherheitsregeln zu
treffen wir uns hier in meinem büro und
nicht in der öffentlichkeit das risiko
ist da es gibt so viele möglichkeiten
jemanden umzubringen
tatsächlich belegen die heimlichen
tonaufnahmen dass der belarussische kgb
auch gift morde plante
in vitebsk gibt es ein amateur chemiker
der behauptet jede chemikalie herstellen
zu können
wenn man ihm größe und gewicht einer
person nennt dann kann er die passende
substanz liefern findet den mann und
bereite alles wo meine aufgabe ist das
geld für all diese verrückten ideen
aufzutreiben
es ist natürlich eine bedrohung von
menschen die in deutschland schutz
gesucht haben und das können wir
politisch natürlich nicht hinnehmen
der schlüssel für das ganze liegt
allerdings in russland der weißrussische
geheimdienst ist quasi der kgb heißt er
dort quasi sehr eng verknüpft mit dem
fsb in russland auch mit militärischer
hilfe russlands hält sich der letzte
diktator europas an der macht
lukaschenko werde mit allen mitteln
versuchen seinen sturz zu verhindern
waren überläufer und verweisen auf den
mitschnitt im kgb diese audiodatei
beweist dass alexander lukaschenko als
präsident der republik belarus nichts
anderes ist als ein verbrecher der mord
in kiew zeigt dass lukaschenko regime
bleibt gefährlich für dissidenten in
ganz europa